netflix's the silent sea ended on one
heck of a cliffhanger what's going to
happen to luna will the truth of the
balhe station come to light this is the
end of the silent sea explained
so what really happens in the final
moments of the first season the final
episode of the silent sea ends with a
rescue ship arriving with the intent of
heading back to earth but not much else
is known for certain including the
health of sung hong and luna everyone
else from the mission dies in one way or
another with the two doctors and the
child being the only survivors even han
who seems so close to surviving
sacrifices himself in the final moments
so that the others can escape with luna
as for the lunar water they have some
samples but there's no way anyone else
can get more as ball hey station is
completely destroyed by the water itself
this gets rid of one problem for soon as
it means that rx and other organizations
won't try to retrieve more samples but
they still don't even know how the water
was found in the first place but with
luna and a few samples soon hung and
other like-minded researchers could
potentially discover the answers for
themselves
for people like captain han director
choi and ryu their desperation to find
an answer is simply to improve their own
status they need lunar water to be the
thing that saves everyone just as soon's
sister did in the case of sung and hong
the two doctors who represent the other
end of the spectrum they believe in the
mission to appoint but they also know
there's no miracle cure to the world
water crisis and from the beginning they
are clear about their value of human
life soon and hong know to ask whether
it is really worth it especially after
witnessing firsthand how brutal and
deadly lunar water really is while soon
would love for the water to be the
ultimate cure she isn't willing to
sacrifice the lives of those around her
just for some dream
throughout season one captain han shares
the same pragmatic logical understanding
as soon but he has his daughter to fight
for so he's willing to do almost
anything to complete the mission but
then enters luna a super-powered little
girl who is desperate to keep the lunar
water to herself soon sees through the
violence and realizes that it's not a
monster attacking them but a girl who
can survive the water through further
investigation it's discovered that the
balje crew were experimenting with the
water on numbered clones known as luna
each time the girls died until number 73
which is the luna the crew meets upon
their arrival even after discovering all
of this han still has one goal and
that's finding the samples and bringing
them back to earth even if that means
killing luna but once they meet face to
face luna is the final straw for han
bringing him to his senses about what's
really important she reminds him of his
daughter who looks to be around the same
age and desperately needs water to
survive the entire reason he goes on the
mission is for his daughter but luna
reminds him that there are other
children and other people that matter
just as much while the water sample is
still a major priority luna's survival
and the hope that she can live a real
life is the true mission
there are plenty of unanswered questions
at the end of the silent sea season one
the two biggest mysteries are luna and
lunar water as there's still not a lot
known about either in the penultimate
episode ryu insinuates to han that
there's much more about the original
mission and the lunar water itself that
they don't know saying
you don't know anything
nothing
about what happened
he's right for example if they were
finding success with luna 73 what really
led troy to shut down the study of
course there's also everything about
luna that we don't know while she can
clearly survive the lunar water it
doesn't just sustain her but it also
gives her advanced healing speed
strength eyesight and probably a lot
more oh and she can also survive in the
moon's atmosphere so how does all this
happen we see the experiments that led
to luna 73 but not much else about her
background as for her connection to the
water luna's bite allows soon to survive
the water's infection but what else
might it do
although the silent sea season one ends
with only a few of the original crew
left standing and a rescue ship arriving
the events after that are unclear early
on in episode 8 soon declares her plan
for luna and herself stating that she
will escort them both to the
international institute of space biology
the show provides a short look at the
iisb though nothing else about it is
revealed as soon states that they can't
bring the sample or luna back to earth
we can assume that she enacts a plan to
get to the iisb which would likely be
explored in season 2. even though it
portrays itself as neutral territory
there will probably be trouble there as
well also there's no way choi or rx are
letting this resource go without a fight
there's also the question of whether or
not to reveal the truth about baal hey
station which is brought up earlier in
the final episode both hong and soon
want to expose the truth of what
happened on the station but this would
likely have huge ramifications for
everyone if a second season does come to
netflix we can expect this plot thread
to be further explored check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
netflix originals are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]